الرئيس الامريكي وفي ختام القمه الافريقيه
الامريكيه قال ان بلاده تتطلع الى زياده
التعاون مع افريقيا 49 زعيما افريقيا
اضافه الى الاتحاد الافريقي اجتمعوا في
واشنطن في قمه ركزت على التغير المناخي
والامن الغذائي والشركات التجاريه ودعم
الديمقراطيه حسب الجانب الامريكي
اعلنت في ايلول سبتمبر في الامم المتحده
ان الولايات المتحده تؤيد اصلاح مجلس
الامن ليشمل التمثيل الدائم لافريقيا
اليوم ادعوا الاتحاد الافريقي ايضا
للانضمام الى مجموعه العشرين لتصبح عضوا
دائما فيها
الولايات المتحده تريد ان يتم اعتبارها
شريكا للدول الافريقيه في ظل المنافسه
الشديده مع الصين التي اصبحت مقرضا مهما
للدول الافريقيه التي يزيد حجم تجالاتها
مع افريقيا عن الولايات المتحده باربعه
اضعافين نيابه عن جميع الزملاء قرار
الرئيس بايدنا الهام بدعم مشاركه افريقيا
كعضو دائما في مجموعه العشرين اعرب سال عن
قلقه بشان مشروع قانون الكونغرس لفرد
عقوبات على الدول الافريقيه المتعامله مع
روسيا واشنطن من جهاتها تعاهدت بتخصيص
مليارين ونصف المليار دولار اضافيه
كمساعدات غذائيه طارئه الافريقيه بسبب
ارتفاع الاسعار التي اعتبر مكتب بايدا ان
سببها الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا تم الاعلان
عن تخصيص استثمارات تزيد عن 50 مليار
دولار لتطوير مجالات متعدده بعيدا اعلن
ايضا عن تخصيص الدعم بقيمه 100 مليون
دولار لقطاع الامن واستثمار 75 مليون
دولار لمواجهه النفوس الديمقراطي وقال انه
سيزور دول في افريقيا جنوب الصحراء
[تصفيق]